[Music]
[Music]
I'll be all ready Sokka is gonna come
beam
[Music]
how could that possibly you know what is
missing guys whipped cream with
chocolate or take his image large
thinking on my feet here yeah wow
there's a whole different ballgame I'm
in Vienna Austria is without any doubt
the winner of this one I don't know you
guys have been talking to my family or
something because you're two for two
we talk to Sokka Jim ten shots oh not
good simcha yah-huh be selfish your CEO
Jim King kept guns hot repeat this to
funny baby video what is this is it like
soda Joe Casey I'm Ken I've gotta find
some way to answer in Nome and I'm
walking is there any peanut butter in
here
no no no don't take that my way with
this later
definitely me let's get the schnapps of
a gun sniff surprise alright now we're
talking
and there's strawberry but there
unfrosted but oh I could go for this
[Music]
[Music]
without any doubt another Oscar winner
here that's gonna lose an eye in your
hands everything is a weapon right whole
bodies
yes right now
it's toxic waste no idea what do you
think oh good I'll take it it's sour
whoa my god so mean osteo I like it I
like it a lot better than pets
no I do okay so it's a toss-up I'm born
in Austria and I'm made in America if I
was if both of them were winners you are
such a politician did anybody ever
accuse you of that before this was a
fixed contest it was this was a fixed
contest it was very clear it was one
like one of our elections in America
[Music]